welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford school of medicine today my
guest is Dr David Linden Dr David Linden
is a professor of neuroscience at Johns
Hopkins school of medicine his
laboratory has studied neuroplasticity
that is how Connections in the Brain
Change in response to experience much of
that work focused on a structure called
the cerebellum which is also sometimes
referred to as the mini brain because it
looks like a mini brain in the bottom
and back of the human brain and it's
responsible for an enormous number of
basic functions that we use in everyday
life including our motor behavior that
is our ability to walk and talk but also
dance play instruments and it's
responsible for an enormous number of
basic functions that we use in everyday
life including our sense of balance our
ability to learn new motor behaviors as
well as our sense of timing today we
will discuss the cerebellum and what it
does but Dr David Linden will also teach
us about the important sense of touch as
well as what makes us different as
visuals the reason today's discussion
encompasses so many important topics is
that Dr David Linden's laboratory has
focused on many of those topics and he
is also the author of five excellent
popular books about Neuroscience that
focus on for instance our sense of
pleasure and where it originates from
and what controls it in the brain as
well as our sense of touch and today we
start off our discussion by talking
about the recent discovery of a set of
neurons that have been known about for a
long period of time but that only
recently have been characterized that
are involved in sensual touch in
particular and it's a fascinating
conversation I assure you in addition to
that Dr David Linden informs us about
what makes us individuals how each and
every one of us perceives the same
things differently and it's an
absolutely fascinating conversation
which tells you for instance why some of
you think a smell is putrid indeed
smells like vomit whereas others perhaps
are not bothered by that smell and why
others still are attracted to that smell
or something that you look at or
something that you hear we also talk
about nature versus nurture and how we
come to be who we are not just through
our genes and epigenetics but also
through our early childhood experience
and adult experience and then in the
latter third of our conversation we
shift to talking about the so-called
mind-body connection and the science
underlying how our thoughts inform our
bodily health or lack thereof as well as
how the organs of our body control the
chemicals hormones and thoughts within
our brain then we shift to discussing Dr
David Linden himself and the fact that
in 2020 he was diagnosed with a form of
heart cancer that led his Physicians to
tell him that he had six to 12 months to
live now obviously because he was in our
studio to record this conversation he
has outlived that prognosis but he lives
day to day with the knowledge that his
death may very well come soon although
it isn't clear exactly when that day
will come of course he tells us how the
initial prognosis of his cancer as well
as outliving that prognosis has informed
his day-to-day life as well as his
thinking and his relationships and that
leads to a very direct and frankly
emotional conversation that includes
advice on how all of us can get the most
out of our daily living and out of our
overall life it's an extremely powerful
conversation that I believe everyone
regardless of age or health status can
benefit from and it's one that makes
clear that not only is Dr David Linden a
spectacular scientist but also a
spectacular educator a spectacular
popular writer a spectacular Family Man
including husband and father and friend
to many people and his colleagues but he
is also a courageous and spectacularly
generous human being before we begin I'd
like to emphasize that this podcast is
separate from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford it is however part of
my desire and effort to bring zero cost
to Consumer information about science
and science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is Roca Roca
makes eyeglasses and sunglasses that are
the absolute highest quality the company
was founded by two All-American swimmers
from Stanford and everything about Roca
eyeglasses and sunglasses were designed
with performance in mind I've spent a
lifetime working on the biology of the
visual system and I can tell you that
your visual system has to contend with
an enormous number of challenges in
order for you to be able to see clearly
Roca understands those challenges and
the biology the visual system such that
they've designed sunglasses and
Eyeglasses that always allow you to see
with Crystal clarity now initially Roca
eyeglasses and sunglasses were designed
for sports performance and as a
consequence all of their glasses are
designed to be very lightweight and to
not slip off your face if you get sweaty
however the design of the glasses
include some that are specifically for
sport and others whose aesthetic really
allows you to use them for sport as well
as out to dinner or to work etc and
that's how I use them if you'd like to
try Roca eyeglasses and sunglasses you
can go to roca.com that's roka.com and
enter the code huberman to save 20 off
your first order again that's Roca
roka.com and enter the code huberman at
checkout today's episode is also brought
To Us by levels levels is a program that
lets you see how different foods and
behaviors affect your health by giving
you real-time feedback on your diet
using a continuous glucose monitor one
of the most important factors impacting
your immediate and long-term health is
the way that your body manages its blood
glucose or sometimes referred to as
blood sugar levels to maintain energy
and focus throughout the day you want to
keep your blood glucose steady without
big spikes or dips using levels you can
monitor how different types of foods and
different food combinations as well as
food timing and things like exercise
combine to impact your blood glucose
levels I started using levels a little
over a year ago and it gave me a lot of
insight into how specific Foods were
spiking my blood sugar and then leaving
me feeling tired for several hours
afterwards as well as how the spacing of
exercise and my meals was impacting my
overall energy and in doing so it really
allowed me to optimize how I eat what I
eat when I exercise and so on such that
my blood glucose levels and energy
levels are stable throughout the day if
you're interested in learning more about
levels and trying a continuous glucose
monitor yourself go to levels.link
huberman right now levels is offering an
additional two free months of membership
again that's levels.link l i n k slash
huberman to get two free months of
membership we are always striving to
make the huberman Lab podcast better and
to that end we need your help over the
next month we are going to be carrying
out a survey the purpose of the survey
is to improve the huberman Lab podcast
according to your feedback we put
together a brief survey to understand
what you love about the podcast
hopefully you love a few things at least
or maybe just one thing as well as what
you think could be improved or perhaps
the many things that you think could be
improved about the huberman Lab podcast
basically what we are asking is to get
your feedback so that we can improve any
and all things about the huberman Lab
podcast the survey does not take long
and every single response will be
reviewed as a thank you for completing
the survey we are offering two months
free of the huberman lab premium channel
if you're already a member of the
huberman lab premium channel do not
worry you will get an additional two
free months for carrying out this survey
you can find the link to the survey in
the show notes for this podcast episode
and on our website hubermanlab.com so if
you would be so kind as to take a few
minutes to fill out the survey and help
us continue with bringing you the best
possible content here at The huberman
Lab podcast and as always thank you for
your interest in science and now for my
discussion with Dr David Linden
Professor Lyndon welcome thanks so much
for having me
been looking forward to our conversation
and we have a lot to talk about we do
lots of different aspects of science
lots of different aspects of personal
journey and what you're confronting now
as it relates to your health and your
future
I want to start off with a question that
I learned from the one and only the
great Carl dyseroth who was the first
guest on this podcast my colleague at
Stanford and for those of you that don't
recognize Carl's name he is a absolute
Phenom he's a
active clinical psychiatrist so he's an
MD and he also is a bioengineer who's
developed a lot of the modern tools for
probing the brain and um anytime I've
met with Carl the first thing he says is
what are you most excited about lately
that's a good question it is uh so I'm
gonna steal that approach and say what
are you most excited about lately
well very very lately the most
interesting thing that I read in
Neuroscience is the answer to
a a scientific problem that I think is
really dear to a lot of people's hearts
and that is
what are the nerve endings in the
genitals that are responsible for sexual
sensation
and you know if you think about it right
people can feel sexy from being touched
on lots of different parts of the body
but there's something special about the
genitals doesn't matter male or female
or intersex or gay or straight or bi or
whatever you are you know the genitals
are are a hot spot
and why and you you'd think as
biologists we'd know this by now this
would be something we could just answer
but but it's been a mystery for a long
time and if you go back to to 1860 there
was a German neuroanatomist named Krauss
and he cut thin sections of tissue from
the penis and the clitoris and he looked
at them under the microscope and he saw
a particular kind of nerve ending there
that has since been called the Kraus
corpuscle and there were lots of them in
these two places and so he thought well
maybe this is the cellular basis of
sexual sensation maybe these are the
particular nerve endings that are
responsible
uh for this
um but
there were some things that that were in
favor of that and some not so these
nerve endings are also in some other
places that people can find
more or less sexy like they're in the
nipples and they're on the lips and
they're in the anus all places that get
popular in uh in that domain but they're
also in places like the cornea or the
lining of the joints so distribution
doesn't quite make sense uh and so it
was never known and so if you wanted to
really test as a scientist whether these
nerve endings are responsible you want
to record their electrical signals while
the genitals are being touched you'd
want to inactivate these cells and see
if you could interfere with with uh
sexual sensation and this in a pre-print
from David ginty's group at Harvard is
just what they have been able to do in
mice they found a way to label and
record from and activate and inactivate
artificially uh The Krauss corpuscles
and so you see a nerve ending in the
skin it could be convey angle kinds of
information it could be tuned for hot or
for cold or for itch or for pain or for
in or for inflammation or for mechanical
Sensations stretching vibration
indentation and sure enough when they
recorded from these Kraus corpuscles
they really are mechanical sensors as
you would expect uh if they were
involved in sexual sensation so that was
good
and then uh the other thing then that
they did is they they tried to
artificially turn them on and so the way
they did that is they used genetic
tricks to express one of Carl diceroth's
uh uh molecules that activates neurons
when they're when blue light is shown on
them and they found that if they express
uh uh this artificial protein in the
cross cells in a in a male Mouse and
then shine blue light the mouse gets an
erection all right so far so good what
happens if you turn them off well if you
turn them off in a male Mouse it's just
as interested in females when they're in
heat but it won't mount and thrust and
ejaculate as much and if you turn them
off in a female Mouse during the time of
her cycle where she would normally be
sexually receptive uh you find that she
is much less interested she's much less
likely to let him out she's much less
likely to let him finish so this is the
remarkable results
that uh finally after all these years
since 1860 now we know what the nerve
endings are that convey sexual sensation
and like all good science then you know
there are a lot of questions that are
really interesting to our everyday lives
like you know people like different
things in bed and have different
propensity for orgasm or or like like to
be touched in different ways well is
part of that reason because of
individual variation in their Krauss
corpuscle structure
we know that sexual sensation diminishes
with aging is that in part because Kraus
corpuscle density is lost from the skin
of the genitals and that's a reasonable
idea because we know for example that
fine touch sensors in the fingertips
so-called Merkel and Meisner endings
also named after German anatomists like
so many things are are also lost with
age so that's a reasonable idea so so
this finding from ginty's Lab has opened
up a whole world of science and I've
been my my own lab doesn't work on touch
but I've been a fanboy of touch for for
many many years mostly because where I
work at Johns Hopkins Medical School
there have been many terrific touch
researchers it's been a world center for
it and I hear about it over lunch and I
got all fired up so years ago I wrote a
book about it I still follow the field
and this is the most interesting thing
in that field recently and as I recall
ginty was your neighbor at Hopkins
before he moved to Harvard that's right
that's right he was one of the ones
ginty uh uh Stephen Shao Michael
Katarina xinjiang dong there have been a
number of world leaders in in the
cellular basis of sensation at Hopkins
do you recall if in the pre-print that
you were describing there was an
experiment where they activated these
Kraus core particles in females it's
funny you should mention that I sent
that exact email to David ginty and they
said they are in the process of doing
that right now and they don't quite know
yet and so I asked him I said so for
example is erection of the clitoris even
a thing in mice he says well we're
really not sure so we're activating the
Kraus corpuscles in female mice and
we're just kind of staring at it and
looking and see if anything happens just
there is you know does the you know does
the the body change shape is there a
color change they don't even quite know
what it is they're looking for because
it's that much on the Leading Edge of
things but it's a good question or
perhaps the female mice would be more
willing to mate outside of the usual
time frame of receptivity if uh these
Kraus corpuscles are are stimulated
that's possible my suggestion my my
guess would be not because I think that
the hormonal regulation of receptivity
is like a sledgehammer and very hard to
overcome but they might be more willing
to continue mating or make for longer
during their fertile time and I just
want to remind people because we had a
guest recently uh Dr Rina Malik who's a
urologist reproductive and sexual health
expert she's an MD and um she made clear
that the the clitoris and the penis come
from the same embryonic origin they are
analogous tissues in different
individuals
I do have one more question about this
sexual touch thing
um
these are peripheral nerves right so
these are not of the brain and spinal
cord they are in what we call the
periphery and my understanding is that
peripheral neurons regenerate and can
remodel themselves extensively in ways
that
um neurons within the brain and spinal
cord tend to remodel less especially as
one gets older out of the so-called
critical period
um is it possible that these cross
corpuscals and their patterns of
innervation within the genitals change
according to the stimulation that people
experience in other words is sexual
sensation experience dependent
that is a great question and so
we don't know because
monitoring this in people is not
technically possible Right it requires
cadaver tissue so you can only do it
once in animals it it it it it will be
possible and it it could be for a couple
of different reasons in other words it
could be I think what you're imagining
is that there's actual structural
plasticity if you looked at these Kraus
corpuscles or uh that you would actually
see them changing their shape or their
size or their or their density as a
result of experience but uh what can
also happen is a phenomena like
desensitization uh that is to say when
there's stimulation for a long time then
the receptors
transiently can become less sensitive to
touch and it's well known
particularly in males that uh that
chronic masturbation can produce
sensitization of sexual sensation in the
penis and that could be as a result of a
physical change a morphological change
in the Kraus corpuscles but it's more
likely to be a change in their function
that you wouldn't be able to Simply see
by looking uh at an outline of their
structure in the microscope
such an interesting topic Thanks for
opening things up with with that and
I'll have to check out this preprint I'm
also a huge fan of David ginty's work
and and colleagues there are many people
involved in uh that domain of work of
course
I'd like to talk about
your recent book and the sort of
underlying basis of what led you to
write it and
what intrigued you about this idea of
human individuality the book unique is
one that we'll provide a link to in the
show note captions and um
it's a very interesting idea that we are
all different especially coming from a
neuroscientist who were trained at least
similarly to learn that sure the bumps
and ripples of the brain and the fine
wiring of the brain is different and we
are all unique and different we have
different shapes AKA morphologies but
focusing on human individuality is not
something that modern Neuroscience or
classic Neuroscience has really done
much of it's really focused on how
people do X or people do y this way
um tell us about unique and tell us
about human individuality
yeah well I mean you're absolutely right
so when I look at the experiments in my
own lab how do we do them well we work
on mice do we work on mice with genetic
variation no we work on highly inbred
mice that are designed to be as
genetically similar to each other as
possible and then we raise them
basically in prism in little little
cells which may not be a good idea and
we try to give them a similar experience
as possible they are given toys and food
and water but I agree it resembles
um a prison of sorts they aren't free to
roam they're not they have nothing like
the experience of a wild mouse let me
put it that way they're uh uh and and
yes there are as you said correctly
there are plenty of experiments where
there is enrichments uh for mice and
they love it so for example in our lab
when we put running wheels in the cages
or mice and let them run overnight
they're active at night
um your average Mouse will run two
kilometers in a night for a little time
and some of the mice are so intense they
will run 20 kilometers imagine
a mouse doing 20K but but it will happen
they really really like it they don't
like being in prison they want to
exercise and they're really bored so
yes to get back to your general Point uh
so much of science is designed to try to
find general
principles of
of function of the brain a physiology of
genetics uh and to ignore individual
variation but individual variation is so
important to our human experience and
actually is so important to to the
process of evolution and natural
selection and how how species uh make
their way in the world that that
it's it's something that that requires a
lot of attention and to me what's really
fascinating is that when you look at the
variation in the way sense organs
function it's almost a miracle that we
can agree on a common reality at all
even within the human species and this
is true of of more of of of some senses
more than others obviously in your world
in the retina we have various kinds of
of loss of color vision uh that are well
known and some other more complicated
phenomena having to do with uh
impairments in the perception of motion
or form but uh the place where this
really happens is in the uh olfactory
system
so we have approximately 400 functional
receptors for different odorant molecule
smells uh in our nose and if you
sequence the genomes of many people you
find that the uh
that the the DNA that encodes for these
odorant receptors is unusually variable
from Individual to individual as a
matter of fact if you take
two different people
on average they will have functional
differences in 30 percent
of their odor receptors
and if you do as Leslie vossel and her
colleagues did at Rockefeller University
and give odor tests where they give
people different things to smell and
then they dilute them and find the
threshold which they can detect them you
find enormous changes from People to
People both in term in general terms
some people are just better smellers
than others but in terms of individual
odors as well there's some odors that
some people can't detect and other
people smell one way for example there
is a uh there's a secreted hormone
called androstenone
androstenone there are some people who
can't smell it at all
for some people uh it smells like rather
Pleasant like cut grass and for some
people it smells foul like urine or
sweat and it just depends on genetic
variation in one particular odorant
receptor sorry to interrupt uh another
uh phenomenal researcher who studies
olfaction among other things Catherine
dulock
um I once heard say that some people
have a gene that
for them makes the smell of microwave
popcorn
they experience that smell as vomit and
other people who lack this Gene like the
smell of microwave popcorn or at least
for them it's not aversive so it can
really be a binary response well it can
actually that's a very particular funny
case so the the relevant chemical there
is butyric acid and also isovolic acid
and so uh there are uh researchers I
think Rachel Hertz uh is one of them who
have given a mixture of these two
chemicals to people if they say this is
parmesan cheese they go oh yeah that's
parmesan cheese and if they give it to
other people and say this is vomit
they'll go oh yeah that's vomit and if
they tell people they give them one vial
and say this is parmesan cheese and they
go yeah and I get another one they say
it's vomit oh yeah and then they say
well actually we fooled you it was the
same vial they said no you didn't you
must have made a mistake they're
convinced that they couldn't have been
the same thing so this points out not
only is there genetic very nation that
uh is responsible for our own
individual's perceive odor but we are
incredibly suggestible
in terms of odors and we we are very
dependent upon them in terms of cultural
context uh and and this can be this can
be learned and and this is Central to
our Humanity in the sense that that we
humans are what I like to call the
anti-pandas
uh pandas live in one spot
uh in in southern China and they eat one
thing bamboo and that's it humans are
the opposite humans can
live in any ecological niche in the
world from the tropics to the poles and
humans eat a wide wide wide variety of
foods and as a result it means that we
have to have a very plastical factory
system that have to be very few things
that we find innately
aversive they're only a handful of odors
rotting meat odors uh molecules with the
evocative names like cadaverine and
putresine are things that even babies
when they're newborn find aversive but
other things happen that they need to be
learned for example
um
pretty much every adult finds poop odors
uh unpleasant but babies happy to
happily play with their own poop they
have to learn that that's disgusting
it's not because babies have a different
nose it's because they have to learn
culturally not innate it is not innate
um there are only a few innate odor
aversions and a few innate taste or
versions that were were born with and
the other things are elaborated
culturally and we can think about this
in terms of how we we we we talk about
odors so for example we might say
vanilla smells sweet
well that's weird that's like those are
two different senses how can something
smell sweet it's like saying it sounds
red right it's a statement about
synesthesia right and but but how did it
come to pass and do people say that
vanilla smells sweet everywhere in the
world well the answer is no
so in places in the world where vanilla
is used with sugar in in sweet foods
like desserts then people say that
vanilla smells sweet or mint similarly
uh
smell sweet if it is typically used
together with sugar but if you go to a
place like uh like Vietnam where mint is
mostly used in Savory dishes people
won't say that mint
smells sweets so there's a parrot
Association there that at least at our
level of conscious understanding feeds
back onto what we call
olfactory or smell perception but really
it's a it must be a parrot Association
at some point in development yeah it is
it absolutely is a paired Association
and it's something that goes on
continually
through your life right I mean lots of
people for example have stories of foods
that they wouldn't eat as a child but
they came to like as an adult a good
example of that is coffee
a lot of people have to overcome bitter
aversion to uh to become coffee
aficionados
so uh you know this this feeds into the
more the more General theme
that
there is no pure perception perception
is inference it's not like there is a
purely
objective world that can somehow make
its way through the senses and we can
perceive that as the truth all of our
perception through all of our senses
both the outward pointing senses of the
world like smell and taste and sight and
hearing and the inward pointing senses
like balance and uh is my stomach full
uh and things like that all of them are
based on experience and expectation and
the situation of the moment
as many of you know I've been taking ag1
daily since 2012. so I'm delighted that
they're sponsoring the podcast ag1 is a
vitamin mineral probiotic drink that's
designed to meet all of your
foundational nutrition needs now of
course I try to get enough servings of
vitamins and minerals through whole food
sources that include vegetables and
fruits every day but oftentimes I simply
can't get enough servings but with ag1
I'm sure to get enough vitamins and
minerals and the probiotics that I need
and it also contains adaptogens to help
buffer stress simply put I always feel
better when I take ag1 I have more focus
and energy and I sleep better and it
also happens to taste great for all
these reasons whenever I'm asked if you
could take Just One supplement what
would it be I answer ag1 if you'd like
to try ag1 go to drinkag1.com huberman
to claim a special offer they'll give
you five free travel packs plus a year
supply of vitamin D3 K2 again that's
drinkag1.com huberman
are there any examples of uniqueness of
visual perception that come to mind I
recently did a social media post
that involved it was essentially three
rings A blue ring
um a red ring and a blue ring in the
center perhaps it was the other way
around excuse me it was red blue red and
um
I asked which ring is in front or are
they all at the in the same plane now of
course it's a two-dimensional image
right
um and
interestingly it splits out into about
thirds some people see the blue ring in
front quite a bit others see a red ring
out in front others see them all in the
same plane and this uh we think has to
do with differences in two things
between individuals one is the
distribution of the cone photoreceptors
which we know is essentially random
between individuals maybe even between
the two eyes and then um and that gives
rise to this phenomenon of chromatic
aberration
um which is the displacement of the
visual image according to the wavelength
of the light and we won't get into the
physics of it now I'll soon do a post
that hopefully distills it in a manner
that's simple enough that people
understand but clearly some people see
certain colors in front of others
um and the person right next to them
could see the opposite color in front
and others say what are you talking
about all the colors are in exactly the
same plane of of vision so that's the
one that I know I'm guessing you know
some others and perhaps some more robust
ones well I think you know perhaps
this is maybe not what you had in mind
but one way in which experience modifies
the visual world has to do with how much
light you're exposed to in the first
five years or so of your life and so
kids that don't get outside are much
more likely to be myopic
and it actually is excited nearsighted
yes uh uh uh when they grow up uh than
kids who got outside and we now know
that at least part of the story is that
light seems to stimulate the
um uh expression of a class of molecules
called trophic factors that you're well
acquainted with that actually change the
shape of the eyeball so it's not really
the structure of the retina or the lens
of the cornea the actual degree of
elongation of the eyeball changes
changing the way the the retina sits
relative to the lens and that seems to
be light dependent early in life and uh
which gives rise to uh uh to a higher
incidence of myopia and and to me this
is really well first of all it's it's
it's news you can use you should get
your kids outside for absolutely all
kinds of reasons and you should get
outside too especially in the mornings
yeah that circadian rhythm yeah I know
that's a famous Huber menesque uh uh uh
point they're gonna be putting me in the
grave David and I'm going to be telling
people to uh or it'll maybe it'll be on
my Tombstone he'll say get get sunlight
in your eyes especially especially on
cloudy days because there is still
sunlight even if you can't see the
physical object of the sun on cloudy
days
well you know I think this whole idea of
having traits that are dependent upon
early life experience is fascinating
because there are a number of situations
where you would guess that something is
genetic
but it isn't it's actually dependent on
early life experience and there's a
there's an amazing story about this
having to do with the early days of
World War II
so in the early days of World War II the
Japanese Army just swept through Asia
they defeated the the British and
Malaysia and Singapore they overrun
Thailand and Burma and they were
knocking on the gates of India and
everything was going great except the
Japanese Army had a problem there were
an enormous number of their soldiers who
became incapacitated with heat stroke
they got their core temperature got too
hot
and when the Army doctors uh examine
them they found this was much more
likely to happen in soldiers who came
from the northern part of Japan Hokkaido
where it's uh where it snows in the
winter as opposed to the southern part
of Japan like Kyushu which is a
semi-tropical environment and the
classical explanation the biologists
like us would guess would say oh all
right well this has happened genetically
over many years uh you have a family
that's been in Kyushu for many
generations and you've selected four
Gene variants that allow you to tolerate
the heat better and we know actually
what this is so if you're more heat
tolerant it's because you have more of a
particular class of sweat gland called
the ekrine sweat glands the sort of salt
water sweat glands not the Liberty
stinky armpit sweat glands called the
apricorn ones the echron ones you have a
higher fraction of them that are
innervated meaning that the signals from
your brain that say your core is too hot
can then make you sweat so the total
density of sweat glands between northern
and southern
soldiers in Japan wasn't different but
the southern soldiers tend to have a
higher degree of innervation all right
so okay well this happened genetically
over many generations but if you look at
those rare cases where you had soldiers
from a long-established northern family
and their parents moved South and then
they grew up in the southern location
they had high sweat gland innervation
they were well tolerant conversely if
you had a well-established Southern
Kyushu family and they moved to Hokkaido
and then had their child that child
developed
the northern sweat gland innervation
pattern so meaning less nerve
innervation of those sweat glands as you
mentioned before just as many sweat
glands just less nerve innervation
therefore those sweat glands could not
be activated they couldn't dump heat as
well their heat tolerance was lower
exactly right and and what's what's
what's wonderful is that this
gives an advantage that you can't get
through Evolution and that it can happen
right away in this in in one generation
right evolutionary change is slow right
and you can adapt as a species and as a
family over over many many many
generations but when you have a
phenomenon that is set by uh early life
experience well then you can benefit
from that early life experience within
your own life it's not that your great
great great great grandchildren will
ultimately benefit you
benefit another wonderful example of
this uh comes from field mice voles and
we were talking earlier about how we
both worked with the scientist Irv
Zucker at uh at Berkeley who was a
specialist in uh in in involves and uh
what people found is that if you take a
wild caught uh field mice and uh you
have uh pregnant mothers and you have
them in the lab but you manipulate the
lights so that uh you have artificial
spring in other words day length is
getting longer day after day during the
pregnancy then what happens is when
their pups were are born they will have
a low density of fur anticipating summer
temperatures
uh if you however uh put them in
artificial fall where day length is
getting shorter uh they will be born now
with high density of for anticipating
winter temperatures and of course you
can do this no matter what the season
actually is in the world by manipulating
these lights in the lab and so like the
sweating Japanese soldiers this is a
great example of early life plasticity
and just the sort of trait that if you
ask someone they would probably guess is
heritable but actually is not
thanks for mentioning Irv Zucker who has
you also mentioned was an advisor to us
both who's done incredible work in
circadian biology seasonal rhythms
hormones and behavior I have such
reverence for Irv and the experiment you
mentioned made me smile wide because
it's but one of gosh maybe hundreds of
incredible studies so if people are
interested in seasonal rhythms and
circadian rhythms and
biology of the most interesting kind
definitely check out Irving zucker's
work at Berkeley we'll I'll provide a
link to his uh PubMed uh there since
we've been taking a tour of individual
variation in olfactory perception visual
perception and uh now heat tolerance
um I have to ask are you aware of any
examples off the top of your head
um in the auditory domain that
particularly Intrigue you
yeah well I would say one really
interesting example has to do with
perfect pitch
So Perfect Pitch as a trait that is to
say uh you have the ability uh to to
hear a note play it and say oh that's a
C sharp right this is a pretty rare
trait so even if you look among highly
trained musicians if you went to Peabody
conservatory at my University at Johns
Hopkins and tested people there you
would find a higher incidence of Perfect
Pitch than you would in the general
population but still maybe one in ten
trained musicians have perfect pitch and
parenthetically having Perfect Pitch
doesn't necessarily make you a better
musician but it's an interesting
phenomena and so the question is well is
perfect pitch heritable and the answer
is when you look at twin studies where
which is what we use to estimate
heritability the answer is it's kind of
low if there's a heritable component but
it accounts for uh my recollection is on
the on the order of 30 40 percent yes of
the variability imperfect pitch however
if people receive ear training starting
at a young age
the chance that they will develop
Perfect Pitch can
improve drastically in your book unique
uh do you cover aspects of human
individuality that extend beyond the
percept chin domain into the cognitive
domain well yeah absolutely and uh you
know I think
I think it's good to set the stage here
if we're going to be talking about
heritability and human individuality and
and so if I can go off on a little bit
of a riff uh uh for the benefit of your
of your listeners and viewers here so
if you look at human traits whether
they're behavioral traits like shyness
or very straightforward morphological
traits like height
uh what you tend to find is that there
are very few traits that are entirely
heritable where all their variability
can be predicted based on the gene
variants you get from your mother and
father and there are a few traits that
are absolutely unheritable but that most
fall in between so let me give an
example
everyone in the world has either wet or
dry earwax
and it turns out that this is determined
by variation in the single Gene the name
of the gene is boring it's abcc11 uh
it's a ion transporter and uh there's a
variation in this Gene gives rise to
either web or dry earwax it doesn't
matter how your parents raised you it
doesn't matter what foods you ate
growing up doesn't matter what what uh
diseases your mother had when you're on
the womb it's 100 percent
heritable well does this mean that
abcc11 we should call it the earwax type
Gene well no because it's not there just
for that like this this Gene is
expressed in cells in all parts of the
body doing all kinds of things earwax is
just something that we notice genes
don't code for traits they code for
proteins and so we have to be careful
about how we refer to them in that way
um for example the wet earwax G variant
of the abcc 11 Gene also confers a
slightly higher risk for breast cancer
uh
so clearly it's not just for earwax it's
it's for a bunch of things most of which
we don't yet
know about but in the case of earwax
this trade is 100 heritable
at the other end of the scale speech
accent is zero percent heritable it is
entirely dependent upon the speech that
you experience uh in your childhood and
interestingly it's the speech of your
peers more than the speech of your
family which is why the children of
immigrants sound like the place where
they wound up not like their parents
and there is no evidence for any degree
of heritability not just to be clear I'm
talking about speech accent like whether
you have a high or a low voice or it's
nasal or more or less resonant these are
physical things having to do with the
vocal tract and they are in part
heritable Okay so we've got one thing
that's 100 heritable one thing is zero
percent heritable but where do most
Things Fall most Things fall in the
middle
uh uh one of the most heritable traits
that we know about in humans is height
and in the United States height is about
85 percent heritable 85 percent of the
variation in the trade of height can be
explained uh by what you inherit from
your mother and your father
well what's the rest well it's nutrition
it's the diseases you fought off it's
also random variation which we'll talk
about a lot later
um now you might say okay well that's an
estimate for people in the U.S is this
true all over the world well no
if you go to a place where people
routinely
don't get enough nutrition and are
routinely fighting off infectious
diseases like this has been studied in
rural Bolivia for example or rural India
now height is no longer 85 percent
heritable it's only 50 percent terrible
why because
people in
these situations where they don't get
enough nourishment where they're
fighting off these diseases can't live
up to their genetic potential
for height
if you want to make things better for
the people of the world then everyone
needs to have
basic things like the ability to learn
and enough nutrition and and decent
Medical Care and schools in order to
fulfill their genetic potential for
positive
traits and uh height I've used as an
example because it is very
uncontroversial but we could apply the
very same analysis to intelligence
general intelligence now there are
people who argue about do things like IQ
tests really measure anything real and
there's been a lot of fighting in the
scientific literature about this but I
think intelligence tests aren't perfect
and they are sometimes culture bound but
they are actually quite predictive of of
of of of later success and uh much more
so than say sat tests or GRE tests or
mcats or other standardized tests
presumably those correlate in some way
they do Baidu but but but the IQ tests
are better actually they're talking
about the the classic IQ test I am
talking about the modern variants of the
classic IQ tests that are administered
by trans psychologists uh and aren't
just a paper form and so they're not
perfect and no test will be perfect but
they're pretty good and so then if you
ask the question well what is the
heritage ability for IQ test score
well the answer tends to be different
depending upon the population if you
look again in in countries like the us
or in Western Europe that are fairly
affluent where where people tend to have
good access to to nutrition and medical
care and schooling and kids get to play
and they're not and they're not
traumatized by War then uh then IQ test
score is heritable in the ballpark of
60 70 percent
but if you look at people who don't have
those benefits who are poor and this can
be in the United States as well if you
look at uh communities that that uh face
discrimination and have consistently
poor poor health care in schools then IQ
is less heritable why for the very same
reason that it is in height because
people can't live up to their genetic
potential when they don't have the basic
things that everybody needs
so presumably if two identical twins
and I realize they aren't identical but
you're familiar with twins you have twin
children
um if two identical twins
are raised separately uh
the correlation in their IQ it can only
is it that only 60 I think you said
about 66 percent of their IQ can be
predicted on the basis of their genetic
makeup Alone
um I mean it makes perfect sense to me
as to why if one of those twins went to
schools that were demanding of you know
a lot of different topic matter and the
other one went to schools where the
instruction level was really deficient
that
one would perform far less well on an IQ
test unless of course the IQ test isn't
tapping into school-based knowledge it's
tapping into some other
um thermometer of of so-called
intelligence or IQ well you know the
thing is that good schools
correlate with many other things right
so the students that go to good schools
aren't just benefiting from good schools
they tend to also have good medical care
and safer less traumatizing
neighborhoods and they're more likely to
have books parents with books in the
home and uh uh and and a whole number of
things that are all beneficial so when
you try to do epidemiology on this you
have to be aware that things are very
deeply interconnected but but you bring
up a good point so it turns out that the
way we get these estimates of
heritability there's two ways one way is
to compare
so-called identical or monozygotic twins
with so-called fraternal or dizygotic
twins so the identical twins will share
nearly a hundred percent of their Gene
variants and on average fraternal twins
share 50 percent of their uh of their
Gene variants and generally speaking
when people do these studies in order to
avoid confounds of sex they'll compare
same-sex fraternal twins so boys to boys
and girls to girls uh uh and uh when you
put these incidents into a formula
called Fischer's equation then you can
come up with an estimate of the
heritability of the trade but there is
an assumption
presence in that and it's called the
equal environment assumption you're
saying well two kids raised in the same
family have the same environments
well that's not always true right that
can be violated by a number of uh of
different situations so it turns out
that a more powerful but much more
difficult way to estimate heritability
is by looking at twins reared apart
either identical twins or fraternal
twins reared apart and there was a
landmark study called the Minnesota
study of twins reared apart which is
abbreviated mystra
that is really the gold standard for
assessing the heritability of many
different human traits both behavioral
traits but also disease incidents but of
course it's a small M because you know
the population of identical twins reared
apart that you can get into the lab
isn't
isn't that large they had something I
don't remember the exact numbers but
they had something like 80 some uh
identicals and 50 some fraternals uh in
their in their sample but by doing this
they were able to come up with a lot of
interesting estimates and so for example
most uh personality traits uh what the
psychologists uh use the acronym ocean
to mean openness conscientiousness
empathy agreeableness and neuroticism I
think I got that right
spelled right uh that these traits on
average tend to be about 50 percent
heritable
and so okay you say right well fifty
percent of those personality traits is
heritable the rest has got to be like
how you were raised it's got to be in
your family and so everyone was shocked
when they actually did the analysis
um and found that family has almost
nothing to do with it
is
what what are are you kidding it's it's
it's it's it's it's got to
and I think the important thing to
realize is these traits I just listed
you know we call these personality
traits but they are not the sum total of
the way you are in the world parents can
inculcate many things in their children
they can demonstrate trades so people
are much more likely to go into an
occupation if their parents did they can
inculcate moral ideas and religious
ideas but in terms of these ocean
personality traits they have
astonishingly little to do with it so
then this brings up the question well if
50 of the variation in these personality
traits
is not from your genetics and it's not
from your family where does it come from
and the answer seems to be is that it
comes from the random nature of the
development of the body and the nervous
system and this is this is a point that
I think many people don't understand
this is something that biologists know
but we've done a very poor job of
communicating
to the general public The genome all
your DNA all three billion bases of DNA
all 19 000 or so genes
in a human don't make a blueprint
for making your body and brain there
it's not a schematic diagram that
connects everything to everything
particularly in the nervous system where
we have these hundreds of trillions of
connections rather it's a rather vague
recipe
so the The genome doesn't say oh okay
you glutamate using neuron in the brain
region called the thalamus you know grow
for 200 microns towards the top and then
and then and then cross the midline and
then grow towards the ear for you know
another distance no it says something
like hey you bunch of glutamate neurons
in the thalamus over here in this area
about half of you cross the midline and
so what does this mean in terms of
individual variation well it means well
first for for some individuals 40 of
their axons will cross the midline of
the brain and for another
individual 60 will
in identical twins and as you correctly
said a moment ago identical twins aren't
really identical either in their bodies
or their temperament so if you take
newborn identical twins and you give
them a CT scan just to measure the shape
of their organs they're not the same you
might have one twin whose spleen is 30
larger than the than the other Twins or
whose liver is 30 smaller than the other
twins even though they have the exact
same DNA and they're relying right next
to each other in the womb and presumably
have the same or very similar
fetal environment and the reason is the
random or as we say stochastic nature of
neural development a great way to study
this is with nine banded armadillos I
know we're getting weird here but I love
the armadillo because I've been told
tell me I don't want to uh uh interrupt
you too long but um
as far as I know the only animal in
North America that carries leprosy uh
that is that is true and um and there's
a lot of twinning going on in Armadillos
right well what there is is actually
quadding
so armadillos or the nine-bounded
armadillo in particular and they're
different armadillos I'm not really an
armadillo specialist I don't know if
this holds for all of them but the nine
banded armadillo is born as identical
quadruplets
awesome awesome so you can take these
identical quadruplet newly born
armadillo I don't know you think you
call them pups I don't know what a baby
armadillo was called I'm sure there's
some particular word for it and someone
will tell us I'm sure someone like
comments on YouTube what is the name of
a baby armadillo I know like a ferret
baby ferrets are kits uh the moms are
jills the dads are bobs I used to be
obsessed with this kind of naming it you
know it's a it's a business of ferrets
or uh what is like a gang of raccoons or
whatever so if you can tell us what the
name is for the baby armadillos as well
as what do you call a group of
armadillos
um you win the pride associated with
being right that's right right one of my
favorites is on on ostentation of
peacocks amazing or a murder of crows
who comes up with this stuff I know it's
a raft of otters I think that I think
that's correct but so if you have four
newborn uh identical nine founded
armadillos then this is a great model
system that biologists can use to study
uh uh stochastic differences in
development and and sure enough their
brands are wired slightly differently
their bodies are slightly different if
you test them behaviorally even very
very early in life they have different
propensities some are bolder we'll
Explore More some are will tend to hide
in the corner more and you know we know
this from the lab you get a box of mice
that are inbred from the breeder and you
pluck them out and they're not
behaviorally identical some might try to
bite your hand some will run away some
will stand stuck still where does this
behavioral variation come from in mice
that are nearly genetically identical
well it comes from a bunch of things
they don't always have exactly equal
experience but mostly it comes from
the pseudo-random stochastic nature of
development
I'd like to take a quick break and
acknowledge our sponsor inside tracker
inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better understand your body and help you
meet your health goals I'm a big
believer in getting regular blood work
done for the simple reason that many of
the factors that impact your immediate
and long-term Health can only be
analyzed from a quality blood test
however with a lot of blood tests out
there you get information back about
blood lipids about hormones and so on
but you don't know what to do with that
information with inside tracker they
have a personalized platform that makes
it very easy to understand your data
that is to understand what those lipids
what those hormone levels etc mean and
behavioral supplement nutrition and
other protocols to adjust those numbers
to bring them into the ranges that are
ideal for your immediate and long-term
Health inside tracker's ultimate plan
now includes measures of both APO B and
of insulin which are key indicators of
cardiovascular health and energy
regulation if you'd like to try inside
tracker you can visit insidetracker.com
huberman to get 20 off any of inside
trackers plans again that's inside
tracker.com huberman to get 20 off and
is the pseudo-random stochastic nature
of development one of the major major
excuse me driving forces for evolution
because you know we hear about mutations
and we always think where people tend to
think rather that mutations are bad but
of course mutations provide the
variation that can also subserve
adaptive traits I mean if you're a fan
of the X-Men as I am a huge fan of the
X-Men the entire series every single one
including the Wolverine movies you
quickly come to learn that genetic
mutation is at the heart of variation
which is at the heart of individuality
which is what we're talking about right
and so genetic variation is at the heart
of individuality but there is also there
are also these other things
right that we've talked about there's
the effects of early life experience and
there is the stochastic nature of
development because if you through the
randomness of development happen to have
like a particularly great liver
you're not going to pass that on to your
children right that isn't in your
germline you won't pass that trait
along just a brief insert here on
germline we had ODed rashafi on the
podcast who studies
um epigenetic transmission and um and an
inheritance of uh of of it's not
lamarckian we have to point that out but
um inheritance of of uh sort of acquired
traits uh does happen and uh the
germline it's the genes that are present
in the the sperm and in the eggs all the
other uh cells of your body have genes
of course but
um the best way to put this is uh simply
going to the gym and getting fit
um does not make your children more fit
because the germline as far as we know
is not modified in a direct way uh in
other words the DNA within sperm and
eggs are not modified according to your
behaviors in most but not all cases
that's right and and as you uh as you
correctly said about oded's work and
other people's work there is what's
called transgenerational epigenetic
inheritance which means that you can
have traits that are passed not from one
generation to the next but even two
generations to the grandchildren that
don't require modification of DNA but to
date that has been shown very
convincingly in in worms
found in plants uh the evidence in
mammals is is really not there yet in in
my opinion and most of the claims for
that and it's a very popular thing to
say I epigenetically inherited my
grandmothers or great-grandmother's
trauma uh
the evidence at Presence is is poor
actually a lot of it comes from
epidemiology most of which came from
famines in the other colics region of
Northern Sweden and they had very good
medical records and they said oh well if
your grandfather went through the famine
then you're more likely to have this
trait if you're male or if your
grandmother went through this then if
you're if you're male this train you're
female or that trait and I mean there
are two problems one is that there's not
a biological mechanism but the other
problem is that the way these things
were discovered is by something called
harking or
hypothesizing after the results are
known uh they did very many statistical
comparisons to try to find something
significant and you know from your work
in the lab that when you do many
comparisons you're going to get some
things that look significant just
occasionally a randomly through through
luck and you have to apply a statistical
correction called a bonferoni correction
when you make many particularly post-hoc
comparisons after the experiment uh
comparisons to set the bar much higher
for accepting that data and most of
those studies they didn't apply that
correction and I remain unconvinced of
transgenerational epigenetic inheritance
in mammals now
let's be clear
just because it hasn't been shown
convincingly now it doesn't mean that it
won't be there are some good people
working very hard on this and they may
well uh describe a mechanism and show
this convincingly in the years to come
but right now uh you may well inherit
your grandmas or great grandma's trauma
but you're probably doing it socially
not through marks on your DNA that
changes how your genes are expressed or
not expressed yes so I subscribe to the
idea that there is absolutely certainly
transgenerational inheritance of
parenting and upbringing right I mean
your grandparents raise your parents who
raise you not always people can be
adopted in fact I have adopted members
of my family
um but I understand what you're saying
correctly
the evidence that for instance some
stress-related Gene was modified during
a trauma in my
grandparents are great grandparents
and the idea that that was passed to me
through my parents that the evidence
there is is far weaker right and when
you think about it well like how did
that happen that had to get into your
your grandparents sperm or egg cell and
then produce that effect in the brain of
your parents and then it had to get into
their sperm or Excel and then contribute
to producing it in you but fragmentation
of DNA and sperm is um or in eggs is is
a is a common
um thing especially as people age DNA
sperm and eggs fragment
um and it's possible that some of those
mutations still allow for viable embryos
so it's in theory the germline could be
changed by
um environmental events well right but
now I think you're starting to talk
about things that are heritable
right you're not talking about marks on
DNA you're talking about the structure
of the DNA right itself and that is its
own
separate issue now I think I want to be
really careful about this because what
is now I think fairly well established
is that you can transfer things
epigenetically over
a single generation
uh if as a result of experiences that
the mother has during pregnancy
so uh for example we know that during
the 1918 pandemic flew uh many women
were pregnant and got the flu and if you
look at their children you find
interesting statistical anomalies and
those children for example the males
wound up going into the army for World
War II and of course the Army does a
complete physical and the records are
very good so you can go into that
database
and you find that uh the male children
uh that were uh in utero during the
winter of 1918 during the pandemic flu
or on average a millimeter or two
shorter you might say a millimeter or
two that's nothing but in a huge
statistical sample of millions of people
that's enormously significant more
interesting is that the incidence of
schizophrenia went up about four fold
from about one percent to about four
percent and even though autism wasn't a
term in 1918 yet uh I think came along
later what we now retrospectively would
call autism also went up by about
four-fold so there's something about mom
being stressed
and carrying the fetus at a particular
stage that seems to impact brain
development in a way that then makes
that child more likely to be
schizophrenic or autistic when they grow
up do we know that it's stress and my
recollection of this I believe this was
um the late Paul sternberg's work as
well uh maybe have that name
um incorrect but in any event that it is
if pregnant mom gets the flu
in the first trimester
you see this higher incidence of
schizophrenia and autistic Offspring
um and but do we know that it's stress
per se because it's stressful to have
the flu but the flu is a bunch of other
things it could be fever could be
um some breakdown in the immune barrier
I just want to open up the the number of
variables that this could be do or do we
know that it's something in the
hypothalamic pituitary so-called stress
axis that is adrenals um so hypothalamic
pituitary adrenal axis
um like is it elevated cortisol
um or could it literally be an immune
neural interaction of some other sort
it's probably the last thing you
mentioned an immune neural interaction
and the reason I say that is that uh
Gloria Choi at MIT
uh uh together with her collaborators
has made a mouse model of this phenomena
so she takes pregnant female mice and
she injects them with something that
that it's she doesn't actually infect
them with virus she puts so chemical
limb that is on the code of viruses that
mimics viral infection and uh then what
happens is that in a way that
interestingly is an interaction with the
with the bacterial content of her of her
guts produces a surge of a immune
signaling molecule called interleukin
17.
interleukin 17 can pass through the
placenta into the fetus and if it's
present just as you said at a particular
point in development doesn't work
anywhere during pregnancy but during
something that is sort of the mouse
equivalent of the first trimester
if that occurs it causes disorder
development of the layers of the cortex
instead of it looking like layers of a
cake you see balls and clumps of cells
and parenthetically in some but not all
postmortem tissue from autistic people
you can also see those balls and clumps
of cells are those balls and clumps of
cells thought to reflect um
alterations in cell migration
they are yeah some some I don't know if
it's entirely known how much of it is
selled Vision or migration but certainly
migration is a part of it and it's very
likely that that critical moment uh to
disrupt this ordering of the brain and
produce these increases in schizophrenia
or or uh autism vulnerability uh are
coming at a point where neurons are
migrating uh during development and uh
so what choice group did is they did all
the things we would want to do as a
biologist so they gave things to block
the function of of this interleukin
signaling molecule and it blocked the
phenomenon they artificially injected
the signaling molecule into fetal brain
when the mom hadn't been stressed and
they could they could reproduce it so
I'm not saying that there aren't effects
of stress hormones from the hypothalamic
pituitary axis that are important that
you mentioned but in this mouse model
system work it seems that you can
produce it through this immune signaling
pathway and and so then the question is
well like are these mice autistic well
how do you know if a mouse is autistic
and the answer is it's actually a little
vague right there are behaviors that
neuroscientists say are analogous of
human autism and one of them is If You
Give a Mouse a marble in its home cage
it will bury it over and over again
compulsively or bury many marbles and
people say that that is somehow
analogous to some of the compulsive
behaviors you see an Autism it's a bit
of a stretch right I mean it's a
challenge to interpret mouse behavior
done in human terms but
um it's a reasonable first step
credible and uh I hope more will
continue to be done as it surrounds the
uh first trimester influenza hypothesis
because it's been around a while
and um and obviously there's a spectrum
of what we call autism Mass burgers and
nowadays people refer to it as sometimes
as neuroatypical there's some high
functioning people with Autism there's
some low functioning people with Autism
and for that matter there's some high
functioning and low-functioning people
who don't have autism so
um but it is something that I think uh
demands our attention and and it that
hopefully will be resolved at some point
because also influenza is uh but one
immune uh insult
um and presumably pregnant women are
being bombarded with all sorts of
viruses and bacteria and fungal
infections and fighting them off we're
not fighting them off and who knows what
the variation in uh neuro immune
interactions exist in there that give
rise to you know
good variation and let's call it um you
know uh debilitating variation well
that's that's absolutely right and so
for one example is that uh we don't know
what the effects are on the children who
were in utero while their mothers were
fighting off covet
right we won't know for uh for a while
or the common cold and there might I
mean there might be nothing but or there
might be something serious uh lurking
there like there was for pandemic flu uh
and will be very interesting and uh and
important to find out
agreed
I'd love to talk with you about mind
body but before we do that I would be
totally remiss if I didn't ask for your
um Broad
top Contour understanding of the mini
brain the cerebellum right the so-called
mini brain and here's why I've been a
practicing neuroscientist for you know
close to three decades I know where the
cerebellum is I've dissected a bunch of
them I
um I could tell you where a few things
are in there and I certainly have read
about what the cerebellum does but
whenever I do a PubMed search on
cerebellum I see an ever expanding
set of things that the cerebellum is
implicated in not just balance as most
people hear but also timing also
cognition
I hear about timing in particular of
motor Behavior but then I also hear that
it's involved in learning and not just
motor learning and it certainly is
involved in motor learning
perhaps that little mini brain is uh
doing 50 or a thousand different things
but
how should we think about the cerebellum
what is it doing and what are some of
its core operations that inform both
what it's doing and perhaps what other
areas of the brain are doing as well
because I can point to the retinas or
the auditory cortex or the thalamus and
yes there's some mysterious nuclei in
the brain but to me the cerebellum is
one of the most cryptic and complicated
structures to understand and I know you
spent some time in there so
what's the cerebellum do well uh
cerebellar researchers like to joke that
the cerebellum is a counterweight to
keep your head from falling forward oh
perfect well with all the texting
nowadays people need bigger Ceramics
that's right that's right probably over
many generations then that will happen
along with an expansion of the thumbs uh
so uh but of course everybody's going to
text with their minds in about another
10 years right you'll have elong's
implants and you won't need your thumbs
at all yeah or maybe just five or my
friend Eddie Chang is a neurosurgeon and
uh works on the auditory system he's
been on this podcast before he was
saying that if in theory and actually in
practice you could just record the
neural output to the muscles of the
speech system essentially and you could
just amplify that and you could text
without actually speaking
um in fact when we read he told me uh we
are actually receiving the signals
as if we were going to speak the words
we're reading but they don't quite
arrive at the place where you could get
a full-blown post-synaptic potential so
you're not actually moving the vocal
Machinery so that means the motor
signals are getting sent out there and
so you're speaking what you are reading
but
you just don't know it that's right it's
very analogous to what happens during
the REM phase of sleep right when you
have commands your brain is issuing
commands to your muscles to to do things
like behave in your dreams to run away
or go here or go there uh but those
signals actually are blocked and the
brainstem prevented from from reaching
your muscles because the uh nerves that
don't go through your brain stem like
the ones that control your eye movements
aren't subject to that blockade that's
why you can produce the rapid eye
movements in in REM sleep but yeah this
is a general theme in the brain a lot of
times you have the output but then you
shut it down
and there are REM sleep behavior
disorders where people thrash and move
in their sleep uh during during REM and
uh it's because this outflow that's
normally blocked isn't isn't blocked
have you ever had the reverse happen uh
I have where you wake up and you're
still in so-called rematonia you're
still paralyzed yes and there's that
Split Second that feels like eternity
where you are wide awake and you cannot
move and I'll tell you it's terrifying
yeah a sleep paralysis and actually you
know it's been known uh forever you can
actually find ancient Greek depictions
of people lying with a demon on their
chest paralyzing them and that is
actually from sleep paralysis later
Hogarth uh did a drawing uh of exactly
that uh so yeah this is a well-known
phenomenon but to get back to the
cerebellum uh as we started
um so
the cerebellum is
as you said definitely involved in motor
coordination so people who have damage
to the cerebellum aren't paralyzed but
they tend to be clumsy uh they tend to
not coordinate their movements they have
a disturbed gate if they're reaching for
an object they often overshoot it and
have to make successive approximating
motions to get back uh to their target
so that's well understood but if you
look through Evolution the cerebellum is
connected to this brain region called
the thalamus and it's connected from
there to many regions including
the frontal cortex where phenomena like
uh like planning and uh decision making
and uh moral sense and many aspects of
Personality seem to be encoded so then
the question becomes well that's very
far away from being clumsy what are
these connections doing and as time has
gone on I've been in this business from
over 40 years now I'm an old guy and so
initially we said oh yeah cerebellum
movement control motor coordination
that's what it's for
as time goes on as you correctly said
the cerebellum has been implicated in
more and more functions many of which
are far removed from the motor system
and if we're looking for a theme about
what the cerebellum does is that it is
there
to
predict the immediate future
it's trying to determine what's going to
happen in the next second or two to best
God behavior and as you can imagine this
kind of General computation could be
applied very well you can see why it's
important for you know motor systems and
doing sports and you know if you're
trying to hit a baseball and looking at
what the pitcher is doing and trying to
anticipate what the pitch is but it also
comes up in a social realm if we're
trying to read someone and predict what
they are going to do is this person
Friend or Foe which is one of the first
things that we try to assess when
meeting someone are they competent which
is the second thing we try to assess uh
when meeting something a lot of this
depends upon predictive circuitry and uh
it depends in part on the cerebellum and
it seems to be at least partially
impaired in people who sustain
cerebellar damage so it seems as if
interestingly
the cerebellum started out for
prediction related for motor control and
through Evolution its basic computation
has been applied to other non-motor
behaviors now I'm speaking in
generalities and a lot of the details of
this remain to be worked out and
understood but I would say that is in a
nutshell the modern conception of the
cerebellum thank you finally somebody
explains to me that a top Contour but
highly informed way what the cerebellum
does I couldn't be more grateful my
pleasure in all aspects of biology and
life the term nature versus nurture is
relevant but
never so much as when thinking about the
nervous system
and I know this firsthand because I've
studied neural development both the
nature side the so-called hardwired
stuff that genes just set up
neurons wire up to that neuron Etc the
cerebellum's in the back the eyes are in
the front the hard-wired stuff and then
the soft wired stuff the nurture stuff
is the stuff that can be modified by
experience
what are your thoughts on nature versus
nurture and should there even be a
versus in there
yeah I don't think there should and and
I have a lot of problems with nature
versus nurture as uh as an expression it
was popularized by Francis Galton uh in
the 19th century a colleague of uh of uh
of Darwin's and I think it's wrong in or
misleading
in a lot of ways so of course the nature
in nature versus nurture is meant in
this case to me inheritability right
what you inherit in the gene variations
from your mother and father
and nurture means like how your parents
or your community raised you
uh the problem I have with nurture is
that it is too narrow a term
that really it should be replaced with
the word experience and experience in
the broadest possible sense not just
social experience but uh the foods your
mother ate when she was carrying you in
utero
um the diseases you fought off or your
mother fought off while she was carrying
you uh in utero the bacterial population
of your guts uh so experience meaning
anything that impinges on you starting
from the earliest stages of fetal
developments uh continuing to the last
day of your life I think it should be
very expansive much much more than
social experience in the family or the
or the community and as you mentioned I
have a problem with a versus because
there's this idea that these things are
are essentially in opposition well is he
that way because of of of his Gene
variants or is that way because of what
what happened to him and I think the
thing to realize is that uh experience
and heredity interact in all kinds of
interesting ways some of which are
oppositional and some of which are
reinforcing a classic one from genetics
has to do with a genetic disease called
phenylketonuria or PKU which is an
inability to uh to metabolize uh the
dietary amino acid phenylalanine and uh
so uh in order to have this you have to
inherit broken copies of this Gene from
both your mother and your father so it's
a so-called recessive trait and
here's where the experience comes in it
only matters if you eat foods rich in
the phenylalanine if you don't it
doesn't matter that you inherited these
things right so that's a way in which
genes and experience interact an idea of
in ways in which then they interact
positively
um think about
athletic ability right so a lot of
athletic ability is has a heritable
component if you are born fast for
example uh then you're more likely to do
Sports and practice them and get better
exports as a result of your experience
so here genes and experience are feeding
back on each other in a positive
feedback loop so there really isn't a
versus a versus at all and then of
course the last thing is that this isn't
the entirety so we talked earlier about
the pseudo-random nature of development
stochastic development and so if I were
to take the phrase nature versus nurture
and reconfigure it I would change it to
read
heritability interacting with experience
filtered through the random nature of
development now that doesn't fall off
the tongue as elegantly as nature versus
nurture you know nature versus nurture
is like if the govs the gloves don't fit
you must quit you know it's got that
kind of Snappy snare drum beats but I
think it's it's a more accurate
so heritability
interacting with experience filtered
through the randomness of development
yeah so we can shorten that up and um
and we'll just call it um uh the Linden
hypothesis you know I I don't think I
can take credit for that it belongs to
other people sure but um but there's a
long history in science of of things
being shortened up and uh coined and
that's uh as important and I'm not we're
not trying to rob attribution here
um uh and the good news is
perhaps you can't call it the Linden
hypothesis but I can all right and what
I've found is as with the Galpin
equation which is now out there as a
hydration it's a formula a formula that
gives broad but
um research informed parameters as to
how much water one should drink in order
to maintain proper hydration for
physiologists Dr Andy Galpin who's a PhD
in uh physiology and an expert in all
aspects of exercise science there's the
Galpin equation there's the soberg
principle so I'm naming these things
left and right all right um where
appropriate and um
so I'm naming these things uh sparingly
and where appropriate
um so from here on out heritability
interacting with experience filtered
through the randomness of development is
the Linden hypothesis and I'll be damned
if anyone's going to rename it uh
um faster than I'm going to propagate it
all right well I think all the the
geneticists will be gnashing their teeth
about this being named after someone who
isn't actually a geneticist quite all
right and their dentists will thank me
let's talk about Mind Body okay
I'm fascinated by this
um for a couple of reasons and I promise
to keep this brief but when I was
growing up I was very interested in
animals and biology and my father's a
scientist and I got very interested in
Neuroscience early
um as people perhaps know and so much of
Neuroscience as I was coming up through
the mid 90s 2000s 2010 to 20 stretch was
focused on the brain piece very little
on the body there was nothing about gut
brain access in the early discussions
and coursework
um in parallels all of that I've been
interested in mental health physical
health and let's just call it
performance and um got interested in
meditation respiration based practices
things like Yoga Nidra things that by
way of experience I understood
immediately had a profound influence on
the nervous system states of Mind and
Body nowadays there's an entire
Institute at the National Institutes of
Health
for complementary health and Medicine
essentially exploring things like Yoga
Nidra respiration practices even
supplements and things of that sort and
there's this understanding that oh my
goodness
the nervous system extends into the body
and the body sends neural signals back
into the brain and so this whole notion
of Mind Body has fortunately migrated
away from kind of um
California Counter Culture esselen
Institute only uh you know
um hippie New Age Magic Carpet stuff
by the way that's not what I believe
that's but that's often how it was
looked at in the past and now people at
every level of science and medicine at
every major university
and in every scientific journal are
starting to publish papers about the
interactions between bodily organs like
the breathing apparati the
diaphragm lungs the heart heart rate
variability we hear about the liver the
gut brain axis in particular and so Mind
Body the idea that our thoughts could
influence our body and that our bodily
State could influence our thoughts is
fortunately not just
understood but it seems to be both
accepted and appreciated
so what are your thoughts on Mind Body
what does that mean to you and
what do you think is the potential of
the mind-body interaction it seems to me
we've just barely scratched the surface
yeah well I'm glad you asked because I
think it's a it's a really fascinating
uh situation and uh where things are
changing very very quickly and I think
to me the most important thing for
people to understand
is that when you have a hypothesis let's
say you have a hypothesis that uh
meditation
can
attenuate chronic pain all right
well there is a temptation to think that
this operates outside the realm of
Science and biology that is in some Airy
fairy realm in the clouds that this
happens and and and I mean for for good
reason there are a lot of people who
will describe it in exactly that way
with auras or they they clop scientific
terms like resonance and energy but they
don't actually use them in scientific
ways so you know there's a lot of very
fuzzy language that surrounds this but
it shouldn't obscure the facts that when
you have a hypothesis that say some
mental state like meditation or or
guided breathing uh uh affects some
process in the body that
you should be trying to understand this
in terms of a biological hypothesis not
in terms of some some some
indistinct realm that that is that is
different like manifestation yeah and
you know I really learned this initially
from my father my father was a
psychiatrist in fact kind of a talking
cure old-fashioned
psychoanalyst how does practice in uh
Los Angeles and uh we would have dinner
together every Wednesday nights and uh
he would always tell me about his
patience he was very careful to keep
confidentiality right he wouldn't
break confidentiality but you know I
would say oh this how's your narcissist
oh we had this dream you know so this
was you know this was this was normal
conversation when I was 14 15 years old
with my dad and one day I said Dad it's
really clear to me that through this
talking cure a large fraction of your
patients feel better and they conquer
their depression or or their obsessive
thoughts or things that are blocking
them how do you think it works
and he says well we don't really know
the mechanics But ultimately when it
works it's not working in some area
farrier realm it is working by changing
the biology of the brain
and when he said that it was like a
lightning bolt went off in my head
and I thought well
I don't have the kind of personality to
be a talking cure psychiatrist I'm not
nearly nice enough
but
I could understand the underlying
biology maybe I'll do that
and so
as you've correctly pointed out when you
say the phrase Mind Body you're talking
about two directions you're talking
about mental functions affecting the
body and then you are also talking about
how phenomena in the body affects affect
the mind and we're understanding so much
more about how that happens and I think
the general thing for your your
listeners to appreciate is that we have
some culprits
here right and generally speaking there
are there are two classes of culprits so
if you want to get signals about the
body to the mind there's two ways to do
that one of them is through neurons that
reach out into the body and sense things
and this is referred to as introception
right so as opposed to extra reception
your outward pointing senses these are
the senses that monitor your own body
and and while we can consciously be
aware of a lot of that information a lot
of it is happening subconsciously like
your breathing is happening
automatically most of the time without
you thinking about it and that depends
upon sensors about your blood chemistry
and the state of your lungs and a number
of other things that are regulating that
process and it's all happening in the
brain usually below the level of your
conscious attention in addition to the
neural signals there is also a whole
realm of hormonal or diffusible immune
signals and what these are is that these
are chemicals that are released into the
bloodstream and that move throughout the
body and that can uh activate neurons in
the brain or in other parts of the
nervous system to produce changes in uh
in mental in mental function and I think
the real thing that is exciting a lot of
people right now has to do with immune
signaling molecules so there's a class
of molecules called cytokines and
cytokines are basically the signaling
hormones of the immune system and they
they can flow through the bloodstream
and through lymphatic fluid and reach
many parts of the body uh we've known
for a number of years that the
specialized receptors for these
cytokines are found throughout the brain
and yet we know very very very little
about
what they do and that's going to be an
astonishingly
fruitful area of scientific research but
but to give one one Exemplar
um there are a lot of things these days
suggesting uh a link between
inflammation in the body whether it be
in the gut or in other places to
depression
well how might that work well it could
work either through inflammation sensing
neurons sending electrical signals to
the brain or and it's not either or it
could be both it could be
immune signaling cytokine molecules
produced at the site of inflammation
that then travel through the bloodstream
and the lymphatic system to then reach
the brain bind receptors and have
effects and so you know one of the
mysteries about depression is that uh
it's not that tractable to
pharmacological therapy so if you look
at people who suffer with depression
about a third of people see significant
benefit from Modern SSRI and related
antidepressant drugs uh about a third
see very tiny benefit on about a third
scene no benefit
at all and part of the reason is because
maybe our term depression is too big a
bucket depression is actually many
different biological disorders and only
a subset of those are are helped by
ssris and will need different therapies
for the other ones that's certainly part
of it
um but part of it might actually have to
do with inflammation so if you think
that inflammation is a risk factor in
depression well you could do something
very simple right you could you could
gobble an ibuprofen right there's a
whole bunch of anti-inflammatory drugs
that are very well understood and so
well what if you just say all right you
know uh let's have a study where we have
a bunch of depressed people and we have
them all eat anti-inflammatory drugs for
a few weeks and we see if this relieves
their depression and the answer seems to
be no
it doesn't
well and that's that's
a little bit hard to understand because
there are definitely links
between inflammation and depression so
for example one of the early treatments
for uh for Hepatitis C that's since been
superseded by more modern drugs was a
pro-inflammatory cytokine molecule and
when you gave it to people to treat
their hepatitis C almost everyone became
depressed
on this drug so he said oh well this
really seems like like like a link
likewise there are certain uh
neurological diseases like multiple
sclerosis it turns out the incidence of
depression as a comorbidity in multiple
sclerosis is enormous and you might
think well there's a trivial reason for
that if you're paralyzed from Ms you're
bummed out about life and that's the
reason but if you look at people who
have spinal cord injuries from accidents
they actually have major depression at a
nor at a rate from people who are
uninjured so that doesn't seem to be it
it's not just that you're bummed out
from being paralyzed although of course
it's reasonable to be bummed out about
being paralyzed but that's not it so
what happens in Ms well there's a bunch
of cytokines including one called
interleukin-6 il-6 that's elevated
massively if you if you take a spinal
tap and you look at cerebral spinal
fluid and so that could be causative for
depression so all these real reasons to
think that inflammation is involved but
yet the idea is still a little messy so
now what if instead of looking at the
general population of depressed people
you look at the subset of people that
don't respond to SSRI antidepressants
are they helped by anti-inflammatories
and there there's a bit of a hint that
maybe they are it's not definitive yet
there are a couple of studies it's it's
right on the edge but I think this is a
really good example of how we are going
to see progress very soon in the body to
mind part of mind
body medicine that is going to be of
enormous uh benefit to people
so interesting could I get your thoughts
on one candidate hypothesis that I've
been thinking about I've covered
depression on a few episodes and um I've
had a Robin cardard Harris from UCSF and
Dr Matthew Johnson from your very own
John Hopkins University both of whom
work run Laboratories studying
psychedelics for the treatment of
depression
the clinical trials on psilocybin and to
be clear so Simon's still illegal it's
been decriminalized a few places but
we're not talking about recreational use
we're talking about several therapy
sessions and then two without psilocybin
then two 2.5 gram approximately dosages
of psilocybin given separately again
with therapists present and then
follow-up therapy sessions seem to lead
to relief of depression in approximately
somewhere between 65 and 80 percent of
people in some cases total remission in
some cases some relief without remission
okay so we can kind of set that result
on the Shelf it's been repeated a number
of different times
compare that to the results of ssris
which seem to help a third of people a
third minimally and a third not at all
and of course there's the side effect
profiles of the ssris and Associated
drugs not just the ssris but proprion
and the other antidepressants that are
taken in prescription drug form and then
there's this uh inflammation piece so
could we hypothesize that relief from
depression has something to do with
neuroplasticity rewiring of neural
circuits and that psilocybin we know can
encourage neuroplasticity
and that perhaps
ssris can encourage neuroplasticity in
some people
not all and that inflammation is a
barrier to neuroplasticity
to me this is the only thing that can
reconcile the the current status of the
of the results and then there's
ketamine-based therapies and so we have
to also kind of set that on the Shelf
but let's set that aside on the shelf
for now to keep it simple
um it seems to me that based on the time
course over which ssris work the fact
that they increase serotonin uh very
quickly but the relief from depression
comes much later the fact that
neuromodulators like serotonin are
intimately involved in neuroplasticity
they can in some cases gait
neuroplasticity that are all centers
back to changing neural circuits and so
what we're really trying to do whether
or not it's transcranial magnetic
stimulation or now we can throw ketamine
in there or psilocybin or ssris
that treating depression is about
rewiring the brain it's not about
chemical A or B per se although
serotonin seems involved
to me what I'd love to see is are more
studies about the interaction between
neuroplasticity and inflammation and are
we seeing that kind of work out there
and um because these results sort of sit
as disparate somewhat conflicting but it
seems like inflammation is is
anti-neuroplasticity and broadly
speaking here I realize there are many
interleukins there are many you know
some of which are inflammatory some are
which are anti-inflammatory but is that
is that a meaningful hypothesis and it
um can do you think there's any hope
whatsoever to actually cure depression
if we if we sort of start to uh unify
the the results in these different camps
yeah I think it's a completely
reasonable hypothesis and I would be
broader and I would say honestly the
relief of any Neuropsychiatric condition
ultimately is from neuroplasticity in
some form or another and I think it's
worthwhile to step back a bit and talk
about what neuroplasticity means uh to
date there has been
a focus on synapses on the context
between neurons as the site of
neuroplasticity and that's warranted
synapses are plastic they change as a
result of experience as a result of
hormone changes as a result of exercise
as a result of lots of things but
synapses are not the be-all and end-all
of neural function so for example
neurons work by sending electrical
signals uh uh along their lengths and
and between neurons and interconverting
those with chemical signals and the
processes of generating those electrical
signals the ion channels that are
involved that are embedded in membranes
that are involved in that are also
plastic they can also change as a result
of experience that's what we call
intrinsic plasticity as opposed to
synaptic plasticity in addition there
are literal morphological changes so
when we we talk about the wiring of the
brain
sometimes we're talking about literal
wiring like cell a wasn't connected to
cell b and now it is and that changes
and then sometimes well actually cell a
was connected to cell b but cell b
wasn't responsive enough and now there's
a change in cell b so now cell a can
fire cell b and that could have been a
result of a change in its synapse making
it more receptive to another transmitter
release from cell a or it could be
something intrinsic and cell a that
makes it fire its electrical signal its
Spike more easily I think that one of
the key cell types that's going to be
important for your hypothesis
um linking inflammation to synaptic
plasticity is going to be a cell called
a microglial cell and microglial cells
are non-neuronal cells in the brain that
are motile they can crawl around they
have long processes and they can gobble
things up they can literally sort of
chew away and digest bits of the
extracellular scaffolding that surrounds
neurons and synapses and thereby renders
them plastic they can uh destroy
synapses and there is a lot of
indication that certain disease States
may involve over exuberant microglia
pruning synapses to a degree that they
shouldn't and we know that microglia are
chock-full of cytokine receptors and so
are responsive to inflammatory signals
when we're talking about inflammation
and we're talking about drugs it's
worthwhile to mention that there are a
lot of Behavioral things that also can
influence the signaling so we know and I
know you've discussed on your program
the incredibly salubrious effects of
physical exercise on mental function so
exercise is about as good an
antidepressant as ssris are and the side
effects are only good side effects as
opposed to the bad side effects of ssris
and again this isn't working through
some Airy farrier realm the reason that
Exercise Works to relieve depression and
the reason that Exercise Works to
maintain your cognitive function as you
age is because of biological Pathways
that we are now uncovering some of which
will involve microgl cells and neurons
and other types of cells in the brains
some of which will involve not the
neurons in the brain at all but the
brain's vasculature so we know that
exercise is very salubrious for keeping
blood flowing to the brain and when
you're young you have a super abundance
of blood flow into your brain so it
doesn't matter if it's reduced
transiently you're fine but as you get
older ah your blood vessels become more
occluded and less elastic and you're
closer to the to the to the trouble spot
and if you exercise regularly you can
dilate and make your blood vessels
including those in your brain more
elastic and that is almost certainly
protective against both depression and
cognitive decline uh as we age
well I am a fan of exercise but I'm
fortunate that I enjoy running and
some forms of resistance training
um
so I always assume that the good side
effects were just the positive mood
effects until the recent literature that
as you mentioned uh improved vascular
vasculature blood flow and reduced
inflammation if not during the exercise
when inflammation actually increases
decreases inflammation I'm delighted to
hear you say the word microglia and um
my postdoc advisor the late Ben Barris
would be especially delighted people can
look up Ben I'll provide a link to his
um uh biography in the show note
captions because he really championed
um to the point of of um I don't know if
Champions even a sufficient word I mean
Ben was beating the drama saying we have
to pay attention to glio we have to pay
attention to glia for the longest time
glio were relegated to these other
journals they even had their own
journals and in the last what is it 10
years there's been a kind of explosion
of research exploring the role of
microglia and other glial cell types and
it's it's really fantastic to see that
this
actually the most abundant cell type in
the brain is the glial cell
um are getting the attention they
deserve
it's absolutely true uh and uh you know
we scientists like to think that we're
very rational creatures and we're not
subject to fads but we totally are right
when I started out in this field
um in the early 80s everything was about
opioid peptides and then there was a
period where gaseous neurotransmitters
like nitric oxide were all the rage and
you know right now glia are in the
spotlight for a good reason I'm not
trying to say sure that that it isn't
worthwhile but there is this phenomenon
of things being fattest and people
jumping on bandwagons and it happens
both in terms of the subject we study
but also in terms of the techniques we
use and right now the technique that is
most fattest involves
um single cell expression profiling that
is creating a list of what genes are
turned on and how strong they're turned
on in single cells and seeing how that
changes in different cell types and with
experience and it's a very it's a very
valuable technique but one could argue
that it is perhaps a bit overused in
that 15 years from now people will go
back and say gosh those folks in 2023
were really overdoing it with the Single
Cell profiling and and if anyone's
thinking about getting into the field of
Neuroscience or another area of
biological or other research I can just
tell you that if you're starting your
PhD or your postdoc take a look at
whatever fad is happening now and just
know that in five years it will be
something different and it takes you
about five years to finish your PhD or
postdoc so pick something different than
what's vadish now and you'll you'll land
right on the money that there's always a
lot to do you don't have to do what
everyone else is doing yeah and indeed
uh the deletion test becomes relevant
here um the deletion test as it was
described to be by my colleague EJ
chuchi at Stanford is if you look around
and you see one or more groups doing
what you want to do very well just pick
something else your life's going to be a
lot more pleasant
um
absolutely I agree with uh with EJ on
that uh entirely
let's get back to mind body
um there are a bunch of different
domains of Mind Body as you um so aptly
pointed out it's bi-directional mind
informs the body body informs the mind
um but we could probably break this down
into a respiration
so breathing
um conscious patterns of breathing
emphasizing inhales or emphasizing
exhales cyclic hyperventilating
Etc
could also be thought patterns
um a little bit harder to break those
down but
um many not all but many forms of
meditation involve having a very still
body not all there's walking meditation
Etc but still body
um focused mind
kind of a not a state that we are in a
lot of times unless we direct that state
um
there are still other mind-body patterns
of communication through very still body
deep relaxation things like Yoga Nidra
non-sleep deep rest there's hypnosis
there's um uh touch-based Body Mind
communication
if we're going to talk about Mind Body
also we should refer to as body mind
um how do we dive in and think about
this because this is involving clearly a
thousand different neural Pathways not
just the vagus nerve it's you know
typically people just kind of hang their
hat on Mind Body must be vagus nerve and
of course it involves the vagus but the
Vegas is an extensive set of Pathways so
um how do you like to frame up mind body
and what's most intriguing to you about
mind-body communication both in terms of
the biology and its practical
applications well I think just as we
talked about how there are two potential
Pathways in conveying signals from the
body to the mind there are also two
potential Pathways at least two
potential Pathways it's a conveying
signals from the brain to the body and
they are the the the neural signals that
are conveyed by neurons that actually
get there and they are hormones and
neurotransmitters and cytokines that are
released from the brand I should mention
that that hormones are actually produced
by neurons including for example some of
the hormones that you think about as
being produced as sex hormones like
estrogen is produced by neurons in your
brain for example
um so
Let me Give an example that I think is a
bit out there but I think is really
really fascinating
and this comes from uh from the cancer
world
and so uh melanoma is a is a is a bad
cancer it kills a lot of people it can
spread it's uh highly metastatic and we
know that melanomas often become
innervated that is to say they become
contacted by neurons and wrapped and
received signals from them and we also
know that if a melanoma becomes
innervative then
the prognosis for that patient is worse
it's more likely to grow it's more
likely to spread
well how does that happen well recently
uh there have been some reports that uh
show that neurons that innervate the
melanoma don't act directly
onto the tumor cells rather what they do
is they secrete a signaling molecule
that has a receptor on immune cells that
are patrolling the edges of the melanoma
tumor and nibbling away atoms and they
when that signaling molecule is released
from the neuron
it
uh shuts down or reduces that immune
patrolling function and then as a
consequence the tumor
can grow and spread and butt off more
readily so this signal that comes from
neurons is sending the ambulances home
so to speak yeah exactly and the signal
is something called calcitonin Gene
related peptide or CG
RP uh I'm familiar with cgrp from the
domain of touch and its involvement in
um I think like itch perception
perception and its perception right yeah
and so all right so if
neurons can
um
can affect the progression of cancer
through their activity and these neurons
in the periphery are ultimately
connected to the brain
through a couple of different hops
um them
is it reasonable to hypothesize that
mental processes could affect cancer
progression so let's say we have a
hypothesis and it's a wild hypothesis
and I want to just emphasize that there
is not evidence for this but let's make
the hypothesis that says that through
meditative practice you can
slow the progression of
certain tumors that tend to get
innervated
right
well right now this is just kind of a
wild idea but I think the important
thing as I've said before that this is a
wild idea with the biological substrate
it's not like you meditate and Magic
happens and force fields open and the
Angels Sing
and then your tumor shrinks this is we
are saying that activity in certain
areas of the brain is increased by this
meditative practice and that this sends
signals to this neuron and this neuron
that actually go to the tumor and make
something happen through this
biochemical pathway that we have defined
right and to me this is speculative but
it's also extraordinarily
exciting right it opens a
kind of Investigation of
mind to body signaling that has received
very
little attention up to now
incredible and I say incredible because
while you're giving an example of cgrp
and nerve innervation and metastatic
tumors
I absolutely love the idea that
phenomenon involving some practice that
could be put under the umbrella of Mind
Body or Body Mind
becomes something entirely different
when we're trying to
hang that on the hook of a biological
process it's like something
fundamentally changes there right
um you know it's amazing to me
for instance that early on psychedelics
and breath work conscious breath work
were lumped together cost people their
jobs at major universities I won't name
the universities because we're all you
work at one I work at another and
there's a third one um called Harvard I
guess I just named them
um but nowadays their Laboratories at
every single one of those institutions
studying deliberate respiration on
health as well as psychedelics and
meditation for that matter with the goal
of understanding what cytokines what
neurotransmitters
Etc change through defined Pathways
including vagus but phrenic nerves and
frontal cortex and all the stuff that is
considered you know classic rigorous
Neuroscience so I do think we've entered
a new era so it's not costing people
their jobs anymore it's actually giving
people their jobs and it's federally
funded which itself is also fantastic in
my opinion so we are in a new era what
do you think
um needs to be done to really
nail down the idea that how we think
influences our biology even though it's
a total duh because everyone knows that
chronic stress for instance is can be
detrimental short-term stress can
actually be beneficial but
um and stress is a mental process that
essentially deploys chemicals in the
body that then create other issues in
the body that then create shifts in
mental processes you know it's so it's
so obvious when it's spelled out but
it's just remarkable to me how this has
just been lumped in the category of like
woo science
um and I can't quite figure out
what needs to be done in order to
convince people that their nervous
system includes stuff outside the skull
and spinal cord and of course of course
of course it would work this way well
right and I I think
it is the job of biomedical researchers
right now to reclaim
a lot of this from
from the realm of nonsense and the
problem is there has been
a lot of nonsense
and you know there's there's sort of a
visceral reaction you know when when
someone says oh yeah well you can do
breath work and it'll realign your
chakras and that is you know what will
uh reduce your anxiety or gut
inflammation and I'm tempted to just go
oh shut up but what if the chakras are
collections of nerve innervation of a
bodily sphincters and you know it could
make sense right it could but it's got
there's got to be some some biology in
some cases these analogies are rooted in
something real and in some cases they're
just made up bullshits right and
I think the challenge is to have really
rigorous scientific tests of these
things to take it back and be willing to
say all right there have been a lot of
claims for example made about how mental
processes can influence the body and
only a subset of those are going to be
true
and of that subset it is our job to
understand how they work both to
rationalize them but also to optimize
them and and make them better I mean
there's no question that
mental processes affect the body I mean
we know for example that if we just keep
you awake and don't let you sleep long
enough you'll die and what will you die
from you'll die from sepsis because the
the barrier between your gut contents uh
and and your perineum will will will
will break down right well so
how does that happen right we're just
starting to understand like there's a
really dramatic example but there are
going to be many more subtle examples so
you've mentioned breath work a couple of
times and I think this is really
interesting
um my colleagues who are interested in
respiration tell me that you can record
in many different places in the brain
many different places in the neocortex
and in other regions and find a
signature of the breathing Rhythm sort
of as a background uh to neural activity
you can find it in the cerebellum you
can find it in the frontal cortex you
can find it in uh the habenula which has
implicated many things including
depression you can find it lots of
places so the idea that conscious
modulation of your breathing could have
manifold effects on neural function I
think is reasonable
given that kind of observation
here here
let's talk about
you a bit uh more uh you've been so
gracious in covering this wide array of
topics and with such eloquence and I
must say I've been delighting in all of
it
you are in a unique position these days
because uh if I understand correctly uh
you've been diagnosed with a fatal
illness I suppose we've all been
diagnosed with a fatal illness of sorts
because
um we're all gonna die sooner or later
yes
um if you're willing could you tell us
the story of how that diagnosis came to
be
what your initial reaction was and where
things stand now and and perhaps we can
explore some of the well let's just say
pleasant surprises that have emerged
since that initial diagnosis well sure
I'd be happy to uh so in the uh the
summer of 2020 uh in the dark days of
covid when things were looking really
bad I developed profound shortness of
breath I couldn't get up a flight of
stairs without uh
uh without huffing and puffing and I
thought oh well I've got covet but I
took covert tests and there was they
they were all negative but I thought oh
I must have covet I've got the symptoms
of kovid I have respiratory issues I'm
feeling weak it's got to be covered and
after a while when this didn't go away
my wife said like you got to go into the
doctor this is crazy it's you got to
find out what's going on and I did and
they uh they hooked me up to an
electrocardiogram and they said oh uh
you've got atrial fibrillation meaning
that your heart is doing two beats every
time it should do one so I have a very
high heart rate and when the heart beats
that fast it can't work very effectively
there's enough time to recharge before
the next beat comes now it turns out
that there is a very straightforward
therapy for this uh atrial fibrillation
comes from uh electrical signaling in
the heart sort of swirling about in a
circle and and reactivating part of a
heart muscle faster than it should and
so if you thread through a catheter in
your in your in your in your groin up uh
up through blood vessels you can put in
a little needle and use that to
cauterize and to ablate a tiny little
strip of cells in the heart that will
produce a barrier that will prevent that
aberrance return of electrical activity
and will cure atrial fibrillation so I
have that process that ablation surgery
and sure enough it it cured my atrial
fibrillation and I was feeling terrific
and they said oh as a follow-up come
back a few months later and we'll do an
echocardiogram to see how your heart
looks
and they did and they went oh my God
there's this huge mass pressing against
your heart
it's like the size of a Coke can
uh here's what we think it is we think
it's a hiatal hernia we think your
stomach has poked up through the
diaphragm muscle and it's nestling next
to your heart so the way we diagnose
this it's kind of humorous they say chug
this can of Dr Pepper
and then quickly get up on the table and
we'll do the echocardiogram and in the
echocardiogram we can see a signature of
the popping CO2 bubbles in your soda and
if we see those in the mass then we know
it's your stomach so I did it I chunked
it I got up there oh no it's not your
stomach
I said oh okay well what we think this
is
a Teratoma and a Teratoma is a
developmental uh anomaly that you carry
usually from fetal life where there's a
group of different cells that gets in a
place where it shouldn't during
development and then grows you've
probably heard about people who
sometimes get like a a tooth that grows
hair in their abdomen Sometimes women
have these around their ovaries and
they're not malignant they don't spread
it's a fairly easy thing but I have this
enormous Coke can pressing on my heart
it may have we don't know have been the
source of my atrial fibrillation to
start with but in order to deal with
this I had to have open heart surgery so
I had the surgery and it was a big hairy
deal I was told would last about five
hours it turns out it lasted two days
wow
um they had me on the heart lung bypass
machine longer than you're supposed to
because you're very likely to throw a
clot and get a stroke fortunately that
didn't happen I I had very skilled
surgeons at Johns Hopkins it was
bleeding so much that they couldn't
close the chest so they had to do all
the surgery and then just leave me
anesthetized with my chest open until
the bleeding stopped and they go so the
surgery was a bear
and then I'm waiting to get the
pathology report back on the tissue they
removed and it came back and it was bad
news sorry it's not a Teratoma it's not
benign it is a kind of cancer called
synovial sarcoma and synovial sarcoma is
a moderately rare cancer and it usually
affects the synovium which is the lining
of the joints or some other places it's
pretty rare to have it happen in the
heart there are a few examples if you
look in the biomedical literature for
common cancers like testicular cancer or
breast cancer there are huge tables of
statistics for millions of patients on
what's been tried and what works and
what the prognosis is for synovial
sarcoma of the heart their only
individual case reports oh there's a guy
in Kenya and he got in this what
happened there's there's a woman in
Minnesota and this is what happened with
her right there are no statistics
because because it's that rare and and
and the oncologist out well
I think you've got 6 to 18 months to
live
now this was about
uh now 27 months ago so I've fortunately
uh exceeded that lifespan estimate and I
think we got to be clear also that you
know being an oncologist has got to be a
terrible job for many reasons but one of
them is that you got to give a lifespan
estimate even if you really don't have
the data to do it in a very important
you can't just say I won't do it right
you got to do it people expect it so you
know I'm not saying like oh the
oncologist was incompetent because I've
outlived my estimate you know he was
trying to do something based on very
little information made his best guess
so um
so
you know I got this information and I
was Furious I was so angry
heart cancer who the hell gets heart
cancer is that even a thing have you
ever heard of somebody with heart cancer
no heart cancer what the f
I've got hurt concern this is this is
crazy time I was 59 years old I've got a
lot to do I can't have heart cancer and
what was
I think transformative for me
is that
at the same time that I was feeling
white hot angry with the universe
I was also feeling a deep
sense of gratitude for what I've had
I've had a terrific life
I'm not that young I've had a lot of it
and I had great parents
wonderful friends growing up I've had a
good career
uh it's been a fairly easy run of it
um and I think
the ability to have a job where you
follow your own curiosity every day
there's nothing like that so few people
in the world get to live that way I feel
incredibly grateful I feel incredibly
grateful with my family and I have a
wonderful wife named Dina and she's just
the best
how do I deserve this I don't deserve
her you know honestly
um so you know in Neuroscience we often
think oh well there's a you know you
have a state you have a set point are
you anxious or or are you relaxed are
you fleeing or are you approaching you
know it's it's like a single axis well
but it is um you know and I think most
people understand that but but dumb me I
I didn't until that moment really
understand that I could feel profoundly
grateful and profoundly angry in the
very
in the very same moments
and
you know having cancer and getting the
kind of treatments the chemo the
radiation you know it's famously deeply
unpleasant and I had all that and it was
just as unpleasant as anyone's cancer
story that that that you've heard the
radiation burned my esophagus I couldn't
eat for weeks it was months it was
painful to swallow you know bad stuff
lots of people have have had to have bad
stuff
like this and and what I
it realize you know this is It's a
deeply
um unempowering situation to be a
medical patient
what particularly when there's something
serious you have you have a limited
sense of agency things are being done to
you drugs go in you that make you feel
really bad and
there isn't there isn't that much to do
when I realized that
for me the sense of agency came
from being curious
from being a total nerd about things
and part of what it made me curious
about was my own mental processes as
they related to my cancer and my cancer
diagnosis
so for example I'm getting the chemo and
I should just say as background I'm
fortunate I I don't have a tendency for
depression I'm a pretty upbeat guy I
don't take any credit for that I think I
was just born lucky and raised lucky
right
but day after day of feeling bad in your
body
from chemo boy it's hard to be positive
it really is I could not overcome it my
mood God really really low and I could
tell myself
this is going to be over it's not going
to go on forever you won't feel this way
forever and you would think that as a
rational person I could talk myself out
of that mood but I couldn't you know
probably because there was my brain was
a wash in interleukin-6 and I couldn't
overcome it I felt really low but at the
same time I was sort of out of remove
being a nerd about going like huh I bet
these cytokines are messing me up right
now I bet that's what's going on and
that gave me some sense of agency in a
time where otherwise I really wouldn't
have them another thing it really
brought home to me is this issue that we
were discussing earlier about how
malleable perception is and perception
of time in particular if someone had
said to me when I was healthy before I
was diagnosed
you're gonna die in five years I would
have gone oh no no no no no I'm 59 years
old I should get way more than five
years I got a lot of things to do
uh professional things personal things
family things I got a lot of things to
do no that wouldn't be I'd be very upset
but you know if you told me after my
diagnosis of six to 18 months oh you get
five years I'd be like five years yeah
that's pretty good I can do a lot in
five years I can
finish up in the lab and I can I can do
some good work and I can spend time with
my family and travel and save her life's
pleasures and do all kinds of things
five years great
and of course it's the same five years
right the only thing that's different is
the is the context
but I think the thing that
really
I realize the most
is that
I really couldn't and still can't
engage with the idea of my self being
gone
so yeah I can do practical things I can
update my will I can write letters for
my people in my lab so you know if I
kick off you know they've got that to
take to their next job you know I can do
all these nuts and bolts
things but in terms of genuinely
engaging with my own demise
I really find that as much as I try
I really can't
do that
and at first I thought well that's just
your own lack of imagination Linden it's
just because
you know you're not very good at this
but the more I thought about it I
thought actually no this is a human
thing
this is a fundamental human thing and
and one of the things when I look back
on the 40 plus years I've been doing in
Neuroscience that's different
is that when I was first trained the
brain was really described as a reactive
structure something happens in the world
you know it comes to your sense organs
your eyes your ears it goes into your
brain it triggers some things you've you
think you make decisions and then you
make an action that goes out to your
muscles or or or or and that's the loop
and that's what the brain does and what
we have known in more recent years is
that actually when the brain is waiting
for something to happen it's not just
idling and spacing out that the brain is
at every moment subconsciously trying to
predict the near future
predicting in the near future
is predicated on the idea that there
will be
a near future that is to say that you
won't be dead and gone right that
there'll be a future
for you and so I think that my ability
which I think is actually a human
I mean not my ability my failure which I
think is actually a human failure to
truly engage with my own demise is a
feature it is it is a side effect of
the fact that the brain is always trying
to predict the future
and so that was interesting to me just
as a way that my illness was revealing
something about the brain but it also
made me think a lot about the world's
religions
religion is everywhere in the world if
you ask anthropologists is there any
society that doesn't have religious
ideas they'll say no they say they don't
always have the word religion they might
just say well yeah in this place
everybody knows that you know the
world's on the back of a turtle and you
know this and this happened there are
these rules they may not call it
religion but every place in the world
has religion not everyone is religious
but it is a cross-cultural universal and
most religions not absolutely every
single one but almost every single one
has stories of afterlife for
reincarnation in which your
Consciousness endures
well why would that be and and in many
religions they've got a deal right
follow these rules in life and then
you'll be rewarded in the afterlife and
that's that's a very a very general
idea or punished in the afternoon or
punished in the afterlife right and
you know in some religions you meld with
the divine
in other religions you're reincarnated
is this or that other heaven or hell
right there's there's variance but but
they share that your consciousness
endures and so why is this so popular
all over the world well I would
hypothesize that it is a side effect of
the fact that the brain can't help but
always trying to predict the future when
we can't imagine the world without us in
it
then we are forced to concoct stories of
the afterlife
fascinating
and makes me want to ask about this
feature of time perception
um
my undergraduate graduate and postdoc
advisors all sadly died earlier early
really by a pretty much any standard
um and I was fortunate enough to be in
communication with the the last two as
they were going through that process
um both of them described
um a heightened sense of gratitude
especially for things that previously
they had not paid attention to
so we call this noticing the little
things yes but
um that makes me
conclude that something about the
knowledge of one's impending death
however far off that might be
um shifts our attention
at least temporarily leads to this sense
of slowing down a bit because in order
to shift our attention to
quote unquote the little things or
things that we previously overlooked
there's this sense of slowing down and
we know from uh basic uh videography
photography that's slowing down means an
increase in frame rate right that uh you
know you know shooting at um strobe
frame rates it gives you the perception
of strobe shooting at very high frame
rates allows you to see things in very
slow motion you're noticing subtle
variations that normally you overlook
um not trying to be overly reductionist
about this uh this process of enhanced
gratitude
that's uh that you describe and how it
was alongside intense anger but have you
noticed a shift in your perception of
time because you were given initially
this okay X number of months and then
now with the you're still here
fortunately
um and with this kind of open-ended well
it wasn't
the prediction that was given to you by
your oncologist but it's unclear how
long you're going to be here right
um which is how most of us exist
you have the sense that it's sooner
rather than later but you don't really
know so I'm curious as to how the idea
that okay you have 12 months more to
live versus
more than 12 months but not infinite but
of course I know that I've hopefully
have more than 12 months but it's not
infinite yes so you know this this idea
of the
the Finish Line the cliff leaving aside
whatever might happen afterwards I don't
know haven't been there
um
it changes what we notice by way of
changing our perception of time
um I mean this is a this is a profound
tuning of our perception
what are your thoughts on that and and
do you notice the each sip of coffee you
probably don't notice each step across
the kitchen floor in the morning you're
probably paying attention to your lovely
wife and kids and things that day but
presumably
um it's Dynamic but what is your
perception of time like now with the
understanding that yes you made it
through the past the gate that was
predicted but
what lies ahead is is uncertain
yeah so that's really interesting and I
would say
definitely my perception of time is
slower
and it seems like an age since I was
diagnosed but I think part of that is
because
it's been action-packed in other words
since I was diagnosed so many
emotionally Salient things non-trivial
things
have happened
so many intense discussions with my wife
and my friends and the people in my lab
uh you know my wife and I've taken a lot
more vacations than we normally do so
you know we're running all over the
world and there's a certain sense of of
packing it in that I think
influences time perception but I would
say actually for me personally
the Gratitude isn't about the little
things the Gratitude is about the very
biggest
things
the Gratitude is
gratitude for being a sentient being
and having that blessing
the Gratitude is for being able to have
a life where I can follow my own ideas
and creativity and my gratitude is for
choke up
the profound love that I've felt from my
wife and my children
you know it's not the little stuff
it's the big stuff that I think about
when I think about gratitude it's not
noticing the sip of tea it's
it's the big issues
and
you know for me I
you know I don't I want to delay my
death as much as possible of course
but uh
when I think about it
part that makes me upset
is leaving people behind
it's not for myself I've I've had a
great life
um I've had a lot of it
I'm 61. I'd like to go longer but that's
that's a pretty good run I've gotten to
do lots of things in those 61 years and
and have wonderful loving interconnected
experiences and so the negative part is
about what I leave
behind
certainly what you've left behind is
enormous
um and has been
the consequence of actions long before
your diagnosis which I think is a is a
clear lesson to everyone
um I can't speak for you but don't wait
for the diagnosis
um you've mentioned the sense of agency
that you felt by being able to
pay attention to and explore your
experience of
let's call it what it is impending death
and
at the same time you as you mentioned
you've Amplified and accelerated the
number of things that you've put into
the world recently writing incredible
articles about your experience of life
and death and we will of course link to
those so people can read them
um I've read them all and they are uh
profound and they don't just feel
important they clearly are important
um so very few people have uh your
insight into the nervous system at the
mechanistic level but also at this more
holistic level that um you've clearly
displayed to us here and in your
research and in your book writing and
public speaking
um
you know I think it's a it's a risky
thing to ask somebody for advice
um but I can't help myself because
um
I think it's a it's a real opportunity
um if you had advice
um
to give to any and all of us
um based on the whole experience yeah uh
all of it from go as they say right
um if if you're willing and feel free to
pass but if you're willing um what is
your advice
well
I would say the advice that is really
Universal
is what everybody already knows and is a
bit trite but I'll say it
anyway and that is appreciate what you
got while you got it and you know this
isn't any big secret
and everyone knows it I would say
for a subset of people the way of the
nerd is very empowering I don't think
that's the case for
everyone I think for
a subset of people who are deeply
curious as their nature
turning that Curiosity to your own
mortality in your own medical situation
can be empowering and
and useful but I don't think that should
be broad advice I think that's only for
a fraction of people it's probably the
worst thing
they could do and there's nothing wrong
with that everybody's everybody's
different right not everyone should
adopt the way of the nerd but for a
fraction of people it's a really really
good thing to do
this is normally the portion of a
conversation with a guest where I list
off the many many things they've done
and how grateful I am and all of that is
absolutely true in the case of you being
here today and the work you've done but
I think it's self-evident how much
you've uh
don't just accomplish but how much
knowledge
you put into the world and not just
scientific knowledge but knowledge about
The Human Experience of others and of
yourself and so I just want to extend a
giant
thank you on behalf of the listeners and
viewers and myself thank you for coming
here today
thank you for doing what you do and um
so great to still have you here
and to have this conversation and I hope
it goes longer and
no matter when it ends you've done an
enormous service to humanity well thank
you that's very kind it's been it's been
a pure pleasure to have this discussion
with you thanks David
thank you for joining me today for this
discussion with Dr David Linden if
you're learning from and or enjoying
this podcast please subscribe to our
YouTube channel that's a terrific zero
cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a five
star review if you have questions for me
or comments about the podcast or guests
that you'd like me to consider hosting
on the huberman Lab podcast please put
those in the comments section on YouTube
I do read all the comments please also
check out the sponsors mentioned at the
beginning and throughout today's episode
that's the best way to support this
podcast not on today's podcast but on
many previous episodes of The huberman
Lab podcast we discuss supplements while
supplements aren't necessary for
everybody many people derive tremendous
benefit from them for things like
improving sleep hormone support and
focus the huberman Lab podcast has
partnered with momentous supplements if
you'd like to access the supplements
discussed on the huberman Lab podcast
you can go to live momentous spelled ous
so it's livemomentis.com huberman you
can also receive twenty percent off
again that's live momentous spelled
ous.com slash huberman if you haven't
already subscribed to our neural network
newsletter our neural network newsletter
is a completely zero cost monthly
newsletter that includes summaries of
podcast episodes as well as protocols
that is short PDFs describing for
instance tools to improve sleep tools to
improve neuroplasticity we talk about
deliberate cold exposure Fitness various
aspects of mental health again all
completely zero cost and to sign up you
simply go to hubermanlab.com go over to
the menu in the corner scroll down to
newsletter and provide your email we do
not share your email with anybody if
you're not already following me on
social media I am hubermanlab on all
platforms so that's Instagram Twitter
threads LinkedIn and Facebook and at all
of those places I talk about science and
science related tools some of which
overlaps with the content of the
huberman Lab podcast but much of which
is distinct from the content of the
huberman Lab podcast again it's huberman
lab on all social media platforms thank
you once again again for joining me for
my discussion with Dr David Linden and
last but certainly not least thank you
for your interest in science
[Music]